[Music]
and joins us in new york city and
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are you both doing doing
great how can we help
um i called you guys because i just
wanted to know
um i'm a little confused whether um i
should buy a car
with cash or
using a car loan where where's the
confusion coming from
so uh the confusion is because of the
covet situation and everything my
husband had lost his job
and till uh
for like at least 10 years we managed to
ride with one car but now the new job
that he got is going to be requiring to
travel to his workplace
which is going to be it doesn't need to
be right now but in the coming months
maybe in the next two three months so we
were trying to buy a car but
just confused what to do
how much is this car going to cost
um
the one that i have right now is an old
one so we were trying to buy a new one
just because
yes just because uh the one that i have
is kind of like on a glass leg
how much do you have in savings anne
um right now hundred thousand a hundred
thousand in savings that's great okay do
you have any debt
except for mortgage nothing amazing and
wow you guys have done really well we
got a real easy answer for you ann are
you ready
um yeah
pay with cash
and i would say that whether you have a
hundred thousand dollars or a thousand
dollars
um that's what i wanted to do but just
the confusion part came up because of
the
previous situations we had where the job
was lost and everything yes which i
understand absolutely so you're saying
hey i want to keep liquid cash in case
something happens
right right ah but you guys have plenty
of money i mean what is three to six
months of expenses for you guys that up
to
um
with the mortgage and everything it
would come up to i would say uh
like 30 000 okay so that means you have
70 000 to play with here uh and the
other side you said brand new card i
don't like that uh because we don't
recommend you get a brand new car unless
you're a millionaire where you can take
the hit on depreciation are you guys
millionaires
uh no
okay
so if i'm you i'm gonna go look for
maybe a a three three year old car
four-year-old car in that same uh range
i mean you guys can still afford a good
car what's your household income
the household household income right now
that the new job everything is going to
be almost nine thousand
nine thousand a month
okay that's great yeah and you're in a
great position i mean you just yeah i
mean you think about it the car it's to
get you to point a to point b a great
used car will do that totally fine you
have a good amount of money you guys can
get you don't have to get a 5 000 car i
mean you can you can spend a little bit
there and and get a new car for you and
even look to look at and i don't want
you to spend all 70 000
on two cars by any means but you have
enough to cash flow because here's what
here's where i would go in in your mind
i understand the the mindset okay i
could take out a loan and have more cash
available in case something happens but
here's the deal if something happens
like a job loss again
you're gonna have a car payment and if
you go get two new cars i mean the
average car payment's around 556 six
dollars a month on a new car so if you
guys just theoretically went out and got
two brand new cars you have a thousand
dollars yeah i know you wouldn't but
just go there you're at thousand dollar
cars a payment for cars
with no income and then you're having to
dip into the emergency fund anyways that
that fund to go and pay off debt so when
you don't have debt you have no bills
you have no risk so
if you go and use some of this money to
go and buy a new car or two new cars and
buy a new car new car to you used um but
something and if something happens with
the job you have no bills and you have
six months worth of an emergency fund in
the bank does that make sense like that
should all give you more peace of mind
than having
a car payments
which ups the risk yeah but it's a great
question ann especially if you're new to
this but we we will never recommend
again even if you have a thousand
dollars in the bank
we're not going to recommend taking out
a car loan because also when you look at
just the math too and for me
you know other debt people um
they justify whether it's like student
loans well you know i'm i'm investing in
myself like right like you hear all
these things but for a car loan it is so
hard for me just mathematically when
people take out a car loan because i'm
like you are taking out a loan you are
paying interest
on an asset that is going down in value
and so by the end of the car loan the
car is worth less than half of what you
bought it and you paid i think on
average i think it's close to
nine thousand dollars on top of what the
original was so like just the math of it
i want you to look at it it should just
kind of make you go well like you'd
rather just pay for it be done
and there's something about it i have
some friends and they've they've always
they've always just done car loans
they've always had you know that's what
they've done and they had to get a new
suv and she was like
we're gonna just pay for it and i was
like that's great you should just pay
pay cash and so a few months ago we were
talking about and she was like i can't
tell you how good it feels
to
just have no payments on a car she's
like i mean it's unbelievable she's like
i never would have thought it would have
felt that great because they always had
the money to pay for a car she was just
like she had the money but they just
chose to get a car but there is
something about at the end of the month
you're not paying to something sitting
right like it's done it is done and you
get to look in the windshield versus the
rear view mirror with your money and
with that new car situation everyone's
always like well it's a new car it's
just way safer i'm like well when you
drive it off the lot it's a used car and
it's just as safe so let's i mean yeah a
three-year-old car is gonna do just fine
i have an o nine and i've had no
problems yeah it's very old you know and
i'll tell you i'm like you know
especially those of you on baby step two
we and we we take this call a lot on the
show of having to replace the car
because there's a truth that yeah if you
have you know we call it a hooptie
around here but you have a car and it
keeps breaking and the you know there is
a there is a point that you're spending
more on the repairs than what it's worth
like there is a point yes you need a new
car um a new car to you but i'm like you
can go on you can go on craigslist right
now i mean you can do anything and you
can get a great five six thousand dollar
car oh yeah you don't have that my car
was six grand yes i'm very happy with it
still drive it today yes i mean and even
less than that you can do but i'm like
there are there are great options out
there and cars
it is that thing it takes you to point a
to point b but we've gotten in this
thing of like we just love cars in our
country we love we love it and that
they're not bad
uh new cars aren't bad but you just want
to be in a financial situation where you
can take